THE. WILL COME TO ORDER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALL. ALL RIGHT TO YOU.
ARCHULETA. èC BE ATKINS.
BECKER. BLAKESPEAR BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. CORTES. DALLY. DODD.
CARO. EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ
GROVE HURTADO. JONES. LAYERED
LI. MAGUIRE. MENJIVAR. MEN.
NEWMAN. WHEN NILO. PATROL BOGUE.
A DEAL. ARGENTINO. ROTH. RUBIO.
THEY ARE SO SKINNER. SMALL
QUAVERS STERN. UMBERG. WE HAVE
WEINER. WELL. MEMBERS. A QUORUM
IS PRESENCE. MEMBERS. UH. LIKE
TO INVITE THE SENATORS AND OUR
GUESTS ON THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE RISE. WE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN,
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. MR
GORMAN. AND WE GATHER IN GOD'S
PRESENCE ONCE AGAIN. REVEREND
DOCTOR, KING SAID. THE ULTIMATE
MEASURE OF A PERSON IS NOT WHERE
THEY STAND IN MOMENTS OF COMFORT
AND CONVENIENCE. BUT WHERE THEY
STAND AT TIMES OF CHALLENGE AND
CONTROVERSY. THE TRUE NEIGHBOR
WILL RISK THEIR POSITION, THEIR
PRESTIGE AND EVEN THEIR LIFE FOR
THE WELFARE OF OTHERS. GRACIOUS
GOD OF MERCY AND JUSTICE. AS WE
FACE THE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES OF EACH DAY. HELP
US TO STAND FIRM IN OUR TRUTH.
WHILE RESPECTING THE DIGNITY OF
OTHER TRUTHS. GIVE US THE
COURAGE TO FOREGO OUR OWN
COMFORT AND CONVENIENCE. FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THOSE DENIED THEIR
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS. AND WHEN WE
FAIL, MAY WE KNOW YOUR CONTINUED
MERCY AND LOVE. WE ASK THIS IN
YOUR NAME. AMEN. MEMBERS AND
GUESTS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH OUR AGENDA. PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED RED. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED RED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ IN AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOVE NEXT TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. ARE NOT
AT THE DESK. MOVE NEXT TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
BLESS YOU, SENATOR ROTH. WE MOVE
NEXT TO CONSIDERATION IN THE
DAILY FILE. FIRST UP IS
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. AND
WITH THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
SENATOR LAIRD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR PRESIDENT. FINAL ITEM
NUMBER ONE IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF DR ALEXANDER RIZZOLI FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LOTTERY COMMISSION. HE'S A
SURGEON AND MEDICAL DIRECTOR AT
RULLI. SPINE IS ALSO STAFF AT
THE SPINE CENTER AT CEDARS SINAI
MEDICAL CENTER. HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY 14TH. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN EYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LAIRD. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS NOMINEE? ANY
DISCUSSION? SEE NONE OF THE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN OF. AYE ARCHULETTA. I ASHBY
. I ATKINS I BECKER. HØI
BLAKESPEAR I, BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO I CORTESI. AYE, DALLY.
IY DODD. AYE, TORAZO. I EGM.
GLASER AYE, AYE, GONZALEZ. I
GROVE. I JONES. I LAYERED. HIY
LIMÓN I MAGUIRE. AYE. MENJIVAR.
AYE MIN. I NEWMAN I WIN. AYE,
NILO. HØI OTRO B¢O. I PAD
PORTANTINO ROD. I RUBIO. HØI èC
R TWO. SKINNER. I SMALL CUEVAS.
I STARTED. HØI UMBERG. I WILL
HAVE WIENER. WELL. AYE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN AYE. I BEEN
PINO. WIENER. SENATOR LAIRD
MOVES A CALL. SENATOR LAIRD. YOU
HAVE ANOTHER NOMINEE TO PRESENT?
YES. YOURS UH, FINAL ITEM TWO IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF DR DAVID
CARLYLE DOCTOR SANDRA HERNANDEZ,
DOCTOR RICHARD KRON AND J
ELIZABETH MITCHELL FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY BOARD. ALL FOUR OF
THESE APPOINTEES ARE WELL KNOWN
AND ESTABLISHED AND ESTEEMED IN
THEIR FIELDS AND BRING DECADES
OF EXPERTISE IN HEALTH POLICY,
HEALTH CARE, DELIVERY AND ACCESS
TO CARE. THEY WERE APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY
14TH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD
RECOGNIZING SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS
MEMBERS IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
LAST WEEK. I ABSTAINED FROM A
VOTE ON THESE PARTICULAR
APPOINTEES BECAUSE I WANTED TO
DIG A LITTLE BIT DEEPER INTO
BOARD AND ITS RESPONSIBILITIES.
UH, MR PRESIDENT, WITH
PERMISSION TO READ, PLEASE,
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THIS IS FROM
THE REPUBLICAN ANALYSIS OF S¼ B
184, WHICH WAS A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF THE
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY TO
ENFORCE HEALTH CARE PRICE
CONTROLS. THIS BILL ESTABLISHES
A NEW BUREAUCRACY TO SET HEALTH
CARE COSTS TARGETS PRICE
CONTROLS FOR EVERY SECTOR OF THE
HEALTH CARE MARKET, INCLUDING
SPECIFIC COST TARGETS BY THE
PAYER. INSURANCE MARKET IF A
PROVIDER OR INSURER FAILS TO
COMPLY WITH THESE NEW COST
TARGETS, THE STATE WILL ENFORCE
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS AND WILL
ACCESS ESCALATING PENALTIES
MEMBERS THAT MY CONCERN HERE
TODAY IS THAT THIS BOARD WAS PUT
IN PLACE, UH, THROUGH A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL WITH VERY LITTLE
DEBATE OR DISCLOSURE TO THE BODY
. UH THAT, UH, MANY PEOPLE ON
THIS FLOOR VOTED FOR, UH, WITH
OR WITHOUT THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS BOARD WAS BEING CREATED.
WE'D ALL LIKE TO WAVE A MAGIC
WAND AND MAKE HEALTH CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL THE AND FOR ALL THAT MAGIC
TRICK, EASIER SAID THAN DONE.
THE OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY AND ITS BOARD ARE
DOOMED TO FAIL. THEY ARE BOTH
SET UP TO IMPOSE PRICE CONTROLS
ON EVERY SECTOR IN HEALTH CARE,
INCLUDING SPECIFIC COST TARGETS
BY THE PAYER PROVIDER AND
INSURANCE MARKET. IF THESE COST
TARGETS ARE STRICTLY ENFORCED BY
THE STATE, IT WILL LEAD TO
UNDERPAYING HOSPITALS. DOCTORS
NURSES AND STAFF FOR SERVICES
PROVIDED AND TO RATIONING CARE
FOR CALIFORNIANS AS THE TRUE
COST OF PROVIDING HOSPITAL AND
HEALTHCARE ARE COMPLETELY
IGNORED. WE HAVE SEEN WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN HEALTH CARE PRICE
CAPS BEFORE? ATTORNEY GENERAL
BONTA IMPOSED PRICE CAPS UPON
THE INITIAL DEAL TO RESCUE MADEA
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL. ALL OTHER
CONDITIONS OF THE SALE WERE
AGREED TO BY THE BUYER AND THE
SELLER EXCEPT THAT ONE
UNSURPRISINGLY, THE DEAL FELL
THROUGH. MADEA COMMUNITY CLOSED
ITS DOORS. PEOPLE DIED WITHOUT
ACCESS TO THE LOCAL EMERGENCY
ROOM AND NOW FAILING. HOSPITALS
IN CALIFORNIA PREFER TO FILE
BANKRUPTCY BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THEY WILL GET A FAIR HEARING IN
COURT THAN IN CALIFORNIA'S
POLITICAL AND REGULATORY JUNGLE.
AND THEN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE LEGISLATURE HAD TO CLEAN UP
THE MESS BY PASSING THE
DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOAN PROGRAM
TO SAVE THESE HOSPITALS, WHO ARE
ALREADY DEPENDENT UPON
INSUFFICIENT FEDERAL AND STATE
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR HEALTHCARE.
YET HERE WE ARE. BEING ASKED
TODAY TO APPROVE THE APPOINTMENT
OF PEOPLE WHO WILL IMPOSE PRICE
CONTROLS ON AN ALREADY
UNDERFUNDED HOSPITALS THAT THEY
BELIEVE WILL SIMPLY COST TOO
MUCH AND MEMBERS. I WANT TO MAKE
VERY CLEAR THIS MORNING. THAT MY
OPPOSITION IS NOT NECESSARILY TO
THE APPOINTEES BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THEY ARE PROFESSIONALS
AND PEOPLE OF HIGH CHARACTER
THAT ARE WILLING TO SERVE THE
STATE IN THIS CAPACITY. MY
OBJECTION THIS MORNING IS TO THE
HEALTH CARE BOARD THE HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY BOARD ITSELF
THE WAY IT WAS PUT INTO PLACE
AND THE WAY THAT IT'S GONNA BE
MANAGED. I URGE REJECTION OF
THESE APPOINTMENTS TO SHOW THE
GOVERNOR THAT HE CAN'T RIG THE
SYSTEM TO IMPOSE PRICE CONTROLS
THAT WILL CAUSE HOSPITALS TO
CLOSE CAUSE HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
TO LEAVE THE STATE AND,
UNFORTUNATELY TO LESS
ACCESSIBILITY FOR PATIENTS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN ON THE
SENATE IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD. PRICE CONTROLS HAS NEVER
SOLVED A PROBLEM. IT'S ONLY OPEN
A PANDORA'S BOX OF MANY MORE
PROBLEMS. I URGE A NÓ VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
JONES. TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I HAD NÓ INTENTION OF
STANDING UP TO SPEAK. BUT I DO
HAVE TO BE VERY, VERY CLEAR. I I
CAN'T LET IT STAND THE
MISCHARACTERIZATION OF THE
CLOSING OF MADERA HOUSE, BUT
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THAT
HOSPITAL FOR THE PAST YEAR AND A
HALF. AND THAT IS THE GROSSEST
MISCHARACTERIZATION OF WHAT
HAPPENED. WE DON'T NEED TO GO
INTO THAT. I RECOMMEND THAT WE,
UH, CONFIRM THIS APPOINT
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
CAVIAR ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? THE NINE SENATOR LÀ YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UH MR PRESIDENT. LET ME JUST SAY
BRIEFLY AND CLEARLY THAT THAT
WAS AN ATTEMPT TO RELITIGATE A
BILL THAT HAS ALREADY PASSED,
BUT TO THE POINTS THAT WERE MADE
, THAT IS EXACTLY THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE HAD IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND I. I PRESSED ON
THE VERY ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED
AND DETERMINED THAT THERE WAS
FLEXIBILITY IN THIS THAT THE
FIRST GOAL GOAL IS A TEMPORARY
ONE TO SEE HOW THIS WORKS AND
THAT WHEN I RAISE THE ISSUE OF
THE DISTRESSED HOSPITAL IN MY
OWN DISTRICT, I REALLY CAME AWAY
WITH THE ASSURANCE THAT THE
FLEXIBILITY ALLOWS FOR THE
CONSIDERATION OF DIFFERENT
FACTORS THAT GO INTO EVERY
INDIVIDUAL FACILITY AND HOW THIS
IS IMPLEMENTED AND IT IT NEEDS
TO BE SAID THE REASON WAS
ENACTED IS THAT THE HEALTHCARE
COSTS HAVE SKYROCKETED WAY ABOVE
INFLATION WAY ABOVE EVERYTHING
ELSE IN A WAY THAT THIS WILL
BRING ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS WILL
BRING STABILITY AND THIS WILL
BRING MORE RESOURCES TO BE ABLE
TO GO TO HEALTHCARE, WHICH IS
WHAT WE SORELY NEED. UH, THESE
FOUR PEOPLE ARE DISTINGUISHED.
UH UH, IN THEIR FIELD EVERYWHERE
, WHETHER IT WAS NATIONAL
POSITIONS IN FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS, WHETHER IT'S
BEEN LOCAL HEALTH DISTRICT,
WHETHER IT'S SOMEBODY THAT
BUNDLES AND BUYS HEALTH CARE IN
A WAY THAT THEY DO IT IN AN
AFFORDABLE WAY, THEY BRING THAT
EXPERIENCE TO THIS GOAL, UH, TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL THAT WAS
PASSED BY THIS BODY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
ON THE APPOINTMENTS. I'LL DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. A HØI OR IY
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY? AYE, ATKINS.
I BECKER. HØI BLAKESPEAR HØI
BRADFORD. UH, CABALLERO. BY
CORTEZ. AYE, DALLY. THAT. AYE,
DORA. I EGM. IY GLASER IY IY
GONZALEZ I GROVE. NÓ HURTADO. I
JONES. NÓ LAIRD. AYE. LEMON.
AYE, MCGUIRE. HIY MINAR. HØI M.
HØI NEWMAN. I WIN. NILO. NÓ, A
CBO. PER YEAR. IY PORTANTINO
ROTH. AYE. AYE. èC ART TO NÓ
SKINNER. A SMALL CUEVAS. IY
STERN. I AMBERG. AYE, WAHAB.
AYE, WIENER. AYE. WILK.
BASICALLY THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLY. NÓ WHEN NÓ. PORTANTINO
WELL. ON A VOTE OF 31 TO 6. THE
NOMINEES ARE CONFIRMED. UP NEXT.
THE SENATOR LAIRD FOR ANOTHER
NOMINEE. PRESENTATION SENATOR
LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. UH,
MR PRESIDENT, THIS IS THE FINAL
APPOINTMENT WILL BE CONSIDERING
THIS MORNING. IT'S FILE ITEM
THREE. THE CONFIRMATION OF MYRA
ALVAREZ FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
COVERED CALIFORNIA GOVERNING
BOARD. UH, SHE IS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP, A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION THAT
ADVANCES CHILD HEALTH EQUITY
THROUGH RESEARCH POLICY AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON FEBRUARY 14TH. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS NOMINEE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS NOMINEE? SEE
NÓ SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HØI. ROLL. HØI
MARETTO. HØI ASHBY. BY ATKINS.
I. BECKER. AYE, BLAKESPEAR. AYE,
BRADFORD. A CABALLERO. AYE,
CORTEZ. BY DALLY. DOD. AYE,
DOZO. BY EDMUND. IY GLASER. I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HØI HURTADO.
HØI JONES. NÓ LAIRD. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE MIN. JAR. BY MEN.
HØI NEWMAN. I WIN. NÓ NILO. NÓ A
èC BOAT. A DEAL. HØI
PORTANTINO. ROTH. HØI RUBIO. I
SAY ARE TOO NÓ SKINNER. A SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN. HØI UMBERG. AYE
WILL HAVE HIY WEINER. I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SALLY. NÓ LEMON. AYE. PATRO B¢O.
PINO. WORK. GROVE. I DON'T KNOW.
RIGHT? YOU. WELL. ON A VOTE OF
31 TO 6. THE NOMINEE IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE. ASK
THE SECRETARY TO PULL THAT
MATTER OFF OFF THE CALL AND CALL
THE ROLL. AGIN. HØI PINO.
WEINER. AYE. ON A VOTE OF 39 TO
0, THE NOMINEES CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA, UH, MOVE
NEXT TO SENATE THIRD READING. WE
HAVE THREE ITEMS ON THE DOCKET.
EXCUSE ME UNFINISHED BUSINESS
FIRST. AND THAT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
. THIS IS S¼ P. 400. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 400 BY
SENATOR WAHAB IN A PEACE
OFFICERS. SENATOR WILL HOP THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. I
RISE TO REQUEST AN I VOTE ON S¼
B 400. WE LAST VOTED ON S¼ B 400
IN SEPTEMBER, AND IT RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH 100% OF
THE SENATE VOTING IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL WHEN AN OFFICER IS
TERMINATED IN A SUSTAINED
FINDING ABOUT THAT OFFICER'S
CONDUCT IS MADE S¼ B 400
CLARIFIES THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES MAY REPORT ABOUT
DISCLOSING INCIDENTS OF
MISCONDUCT EVEN WHEN NÓ PUBLIC
RECORDS REQUEST IS MADE THE
PASSAGE OF S¼. 400 WILL IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY AND TRUST BETWEEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE BY
PROVIDING ACCESS TO CRITICAL
COMMUNITY INFORMATION IN A
TIMELY MANNER. THESE ARE CHAPTER
OUT AMENDMENTS AND THERE IS NÓ
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS.
ITEM IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEE NÓ
OBJECTION. SIZE 39 NÓ ZERO.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN ALL RIGHT, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO SENATE
THIRD READING TWO ITEMS ON THE
DOCKET FOR TODAY. FILE ITEMS
NUMBER NINE AND NUMBER 12 1ST UP
IS FILING A B, UH, FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE BY SENATOR DODD.
HE'S PREPARED, SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 105
BY SENATOR DODD RELATIVE TO
EATING DISORDERS AWARENESS WEEK.
SENATOR DODD. MR PRESIDENT,
MEMBERS S¼ R 105 SEEKS TO
RECOGNIZE THE WEEK OF FEBRUARY
26 2024 TO MARCH 3RD 2024 AS
EATING DISORDERS AWARENESS WEEK
THIS ANNUAL RECOGNITION RAISES
CRITICAL AWARENESS ABOUT THE
REALITIES OF EATING DISORDERS
WHILE PROVIDING HOPE. SUPPORT
AND VISIBILITY TO INDIVIDUALS
WITH EATING DISORDERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. I'VE GIVEN THIS, UH
RESOLUTION. ALMOST EVERY YEAR
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE. MY FAMILY WENT
THROUGH THIS WITH ONE OF MY
DAUGHTERS, AND IT IS ONE OF THE
MOST INCREDIBLY DEVASTATING
THINGS TO HIT FAMILIES. UH AND
WHEN FAMILIES CAN PULL TOGETHER
AND GET THE SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THEY NEED, UH, IT IT DOES WORK,
BUT IT'S A LIFE UH, YOU KNOW,
ISSUE AT BEST. AND SADLY IN THE
U S¼ 28,800,000 PEOPLE WILL
SUFFER FROM EATING DISORDERS AT
SOME TIME IN THEIR LIFE. EATING
DISORDERS ARE SERIOUS ILLNESSES,
NOT LIFESTYLE CHOICES. IN FACT,
EATING DISORDERS HAVE THE SECOND
HIGHEST MORTALITY RATE OF ANY
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER. EATING
DISORDERS AWARENESS WEEK WILL
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND HIGHLIGHT
IMPORTANCE THE IMPORTANCE OF
SCREENINGS FOR THE EARLY
DETECTION AND INTERVENTION OF
EATING DISORDERS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DODD ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS RESOLUTION?
SEE NOW THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THAT
OBJECTION. I 39 NÓ ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WILL BE
NEXT TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 12 S¼
èC R 108 I SEND HURTADO
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. èC
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION WENT AWAY
BY SENATOR HURTADO RELATIVE TO
WEAR RED DAY AND AMERICAN HEART
MONTH. SENATOR HURTADO THANK YOU
, MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 108 WHICH
WOULD RECOGNIZE FEBRUARY 2024 AS
WE RED DAY AMERICAN HEART MONTH.
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE CLAIMS
MORE LIVES OF WOMEN THAN ALL
FORMS OF CANCER, COMBINING YET
ONLY 44% OF WOMEN. RECOGNIZE
THAT CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE IS
THE GREATEST HEALTH THREAT. MOST
CARDIAC AND STROKE EVENTS CAN BE
PREVENTED THROUGH EDUCATION AND
LIFESTYLE CHANGES, SUCH AS
MOVING MORE EATING SMART AND
MANAGING BLOOD PRESSURE. THERE
ARE EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS TO THIS
PROBLEM, AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION. èC PR, ESPECIALLY IF
PERFORMED IMMEDIATELY CAN DOUBLE
OR AAA PERSON'S CHANCE OF
SURVIVAL AND ONLY ABOUT 46% OF
PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE CARDIO
ARREST. RECEIVE èC PR FROM
PEOPLE NEARBY WHILE WAITING FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS TO ARRIVE
BY INCREASING AWARENESS,
SPEAKING OUT ABOUT HEART DISEASE
AND LEARNING èC PR AND
EMPOWERING WOMEN TO REDUCE THE
RISK FOR CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASES
, WE CAN SAVE THOUSANDS OF LIVES
EACH YEAR. S¼ ER REMINDS US THAT
WE MUST CONTINUE TO RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT HEART DISEASE
AND URGE EVERY HOUSEHOLD TO
LEARN èC PR. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AND I VOTE ON THIS. THANK
YOU, SENATOR HURTADO. SENATOR
DOLLY, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I
RISE TO IN SUPPORT OF S¼ èC R
108, WHO HAS JUST RECENTLY, UH,
WENT THROUGH SOME HEART ISSUES
IN OUR FAMILY, AND I WANT TO SAY
A COUPLE OF THINGS NUMBER ONE.
LISTEN TO YOUR BODY. AND WHEN
IT'S TALKING TO YOU BE YOUR
ADVOCATE BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY, IT CAN BE MISSED VERY
EASILY, AND ESPECIALLY FOR
WOMEN. SO I WANT TO STAND UP AND
JUST SAY THAT, BECAUSE, UM YOU
NEED TO BE YOUR ADVOCATE AND YOU
NEED TO LISTEN TO YOUR BODY.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I STAND UP AND
SUPPORT S¼ èC R ONE Ó EIGHT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DOLLY ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
RESOLUTION? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. SEEN NINE SENATOR
HURTADO, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU. I RESPECT FOR MY VOTE. THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEE NÓ OBJECTIONS. EYES 39
NÓ ZERO, THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN NOW TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS, MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS THE TIME TO
ADDRESS ADJOURNED MEMORIES. LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO HONOR THE
LIFE AND THE MEMORY OF JOSEFINA
RAMIREZ, NOT SANNA. HER FRIENDS
CALLED HER. JOSIE JOSEFINA WAS A
MEMBER OF THE CAPITAL COMMUNITY
FOR OVER 20 YEARS AND PASSED
AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY IN OCTOBER OF
2020 THREE. JOSIE WAS BORN ON
DECEMBER 30 1980 TO JOSEFINA AND
RAMIRO RAMIREZ IN LOS ANGELES IS
THE THIRD OF FOUR SISTERS JOSIE
CHERISHES STRONG AND BEAUTIFUL
BOND WITH HER SISTERS, LINDA,
VICKY AND LETTY WHO SHE LOVED
DEARLY. HER FAMILY IS WELL KNOWN
IN WEST ANAHEIM AND ORANGE
COUNTY AS PASSIONATE CIVIL
LEADERS AS A FIRST GENERATION
MEXICAN AMERICAN FAMILY. A
COMMITMENT TO EDUCATION WAS
DEVELOPED FROM WITHIN AND
NURTURED BY YOUR EXPERIENCE IN
THE PUENTE PROGRAM AND
PARTICIPATION IN THE CHICANO
LATINO YOUTH LEADERSHIP PROGRAM.
1999 JOSIE GRADUATED FROM
MAGNOLIA HIGH IN ANAHEIM. JOSIE
WENT ON TO DOUBLE MAJOR IN
CHICANO STUDIES AND POLITICAL
SCIENCE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, RIVERSIDE, WHERE SHE
WAS ALSO ACTIVE IN STUDENT
GOVERNMENT. AFTER GRADUATING
FROM R JOSIE MOVED TO SACRAMENTO
FOR THE CAPITAL ASSEMBLY
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM IN 2003,
WHERE A CAREER IN PUBLIC POLICY
AND COMMUNITY LEADERSHIP BEGAN.
SHE CONTINUED IN PUBLIC SERVICE
AS A LEGISLATIVE AIDE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKIE GOLDBERG.
AND FROM THERE, SHE WENT ON TO
HOLD VARIOUS LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS IN BOTH THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR. JOSIE WAS
RECOGNIZED FOR A STRONG
EDUCATION, ADVOCACY EFFORTS AND
PASSION FOR POLICY REFORM TO
HELP HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. SHE WAS A FIERCE
LEADER AND ADVOCATE FOR
EDUCATION REFORM, AND MOST
RECENTLY SERVED AS DIRECTOR FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD AND DUAL
LANGUAGE AND ENGLISH LEARNERS
FOR CHILDREN NOW 2003 JOSIE MET
CURTIS NONE AT THE STATE CAPITOL
AND MARRIED ON OCTOBER 2ND. 10
SHE WENT ON TO HAVE TWO
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN, OLIVIA AND
MATTEO. JOSIE HELD MANY TITLES
AND DEDICATED HER TIME TO MANY
CAUSES. BUT HER TOP PRIORITY WAS
OLIVIA AND MATTEO, WHO FILLED
HER LIFE WITH LOVE, PRIDE, JOY
AND ADVENTURE, MAKING MOM HER
MOST IMPORTANT TITLE. HER LEGACY
OF KINDNESS, LOVE, RESPECT,
EQUALITY AND FAITH LIVES ON
THROUGH HER CHILDREN. HE WAS A
CONSISTENT SOURCE OF SUPPORT TO
HER FAMILY AND FRIENDS ALWAYS
MADE TIME TO MENTOR AND SUPPORT
WOMEN IN PARTICULAR AND ARE WARM
AND POSITIVE ENERGY WILL ALWAYS
BE REMEMBERED BY THE COUNTLESS
LIVES SHE TOUCHED HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. JOSIE'S SMILING,
INFECTIOUS LAUGH OR COMPASSION
AND LOVE FOR COMMUNITY. HER
FAITH AND HER CULTURAL ROOTS
DEFINED HER COLORFUL AND FULL
LIFE. IN ADDITION TO SPENDING
TIME WITH HER FAMILY AND
CHILDREN, JOSIE ENJOYED
TRAVELING MEETING FRIENDS AND
COMRADES. UM AND FOR, UM, COFFEE
, DEDICATING TIME TO HER GODSON,
HIKING, GARDENING AND SERVING
HER COMMUNITY AS A MEMBER OF THE
MATSUYAMA ELEMENTARY SCHOOL, P
Tð, A MEMBER OF THE SAINT
ANTHONY'S PARISH IN SACRAMENTO,
JAPANESE UNITED METHODIST CHURCH
COMMUNITIES AND VOLUNTEERING FOR
VARIOUS LOCAL CAUSES. JOSIE IS
SURVIVED BY HER PARTNER, CURTIS,
HER CHILDREN. OLIVIA MAO, HER
PARENTS, JOSEFINA. IN LAWS.
SISTERS LINDA LETIZIA, VICKY
BROTHERS IN LAW, NIECE AND MANY
FRIENDS. I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF JOSEFINA RAMIREZ,
NONA. THANK YOU, SENATOR UMBERG
ON THIS ADJOURNMENT. I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR ASHBY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. JUST BRIEFLY WANT
TO ADD THAT WHILE SHE MADE HER
MARK IN HER HOMETOWN, SHE ALSO
MADE A BIG MARK IN SACRAMENTO
AND, UH, JOSIE'S LAST LEFT MANY,
MANY PEOPLE REELING. THE MINI
MOMS THAT SHE WAS WORKING WITH
AT THE P Tð A ALL OF THE HER
KIDS SPORTS. SHE'S A BIG MEMBER
OF THE POCKET GREENHAVEN
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS THE CAPITAL
COMMUNITY. A YOUNG MOM WITH YOU
KNOW, 10, YEAR OLD AND FIVE YEAR
OLD AND OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO
OLIVIA AND MATTEO AND TO HER
MANY, MANY FRIENDS WHO ARE STILL
STRUGGLING WITH THIS LOSS. THANK
YOU FOR THE WONDERFUL MEMORIAL
AND ON BEHALF OF SENATE-DISTRICT
A WE. WE MISS HER, TOO. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ASHBY AND SENATOR
UMBERG SENATE EXTENDS ITS
CONDOLENCES TO HER FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. IF YOU PLEASE BRING HER
NAME FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL. LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE NEXT UP, SENATOR
EDMAN. UH, THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS UH, I RISE
TODAY, UH, TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF ONE OF
MY VERY CLOSE FRIENDS. UH, DANNY
JIMENEZ. DANNY WAS BORN, UM
FEBRUARY 23RD 1965 1956 EXCUSE
ME, UH, IN THE LITTLE TOWN OF
TRACY. HE GREW UP IN A, UH BIG,
UM FARM WORKING, UH, THE
COMMUNITY. UM WITH HIS PARENTS,
UH, HIS SIBLINGS. HE WAS THE
YOUNGEST BOY OF THE FAMILY. UH,
HE GREW UP IN FARM WORKER
HOUSING OUT IN THE ISLANDS OUT
IN THE DELTA ISLANDS. UM AND HIS
FAMILY WAS VERY POOR. AND UH,
AND, UH, EVENTUALLY HIS FATHER
LEFT AND THEY STRUGGLED WITH A
LOT OF ABUSE AND POVERTY. UH,
BUT DANNY WAS ONE WHO DIDN'T
MATTER THE SITUATION. IT WAS
GOING TO BE FABULOUS. UH OUT
WORKING IN THE FIELDS, HE WOULD
STILL HAVE HIS LONG SLEEVE WHITE
SHIRTS ON WITH HIS CUFF LINKS.
UH, AND DECORATE HIS LITTLE COW
STANCH AND WITH FABRIC AND
LIGHTS, BECAUSE LIGHTS AND
FABRIC MADE EVERYTHING BETTER.
UH, HE GRADUATED FROM TRACY HIGH
AND THEN WENT ON TO DELTA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, WHERE HE, UH,
GOT A CERTIFICATE IN HOSPITALITY
, AND HE CERTAINLY WAS THE
BIGGEST HOST. ANYBODY UH, WOULD
HAVE WOULD EVER HAVE THE JOY OF
RUNNING ACROSS. HE STARTED
WORKING, UH, THAT THAT WAS IN
THE IN THE SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES. SO HE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME IN SAN FRANCISCO. UH, HE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME HAVING FUN.
A LOT OF PLACES. UH, HE WORKED
IN HOSPITALITY COAST TO COAST UP
IN THE, UM CATSKILLS IN NEW YORK
. UH TO SAN FRANCISCO. UM AND
THERE WAS ALWAYS A STORY TO BE
TOLD, UH AND, UH, AN EXTENSION
OF LOVE TO BE FORMED. THE
STORIES SOMETIMES BORDERED ON.
MAYBE NOT QUITE TRUE, BUT THE
WAY HE WOULD TELL THEM THEY WERE
BELIEVABLE, AND THEY WERE HIS
STORIES, AND THAT'S JUST THE WAY
HE WAS. UH, HE LIVED IN ENGLAND
FOR A WHILE MARRIED TO A COUNT.
SHE SAID, UM AND, UH, WE CAME
BACK TO THE STATES SOMETIME
LATER. UH, WE KNOW THAT WAS TRUE
. UH, BUT IN, UM WHEN HE WAS IN
HIS LATE TWENTIES, AND LET ME
SAY DANNY GREW UP FAMILY THAT
DANCED AND HE DANCED AND THERE
WAS ALWAYS A LONG LINE AT THE AT
THE JAMAICA AT THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
DANCE OR AT ANY CLUB. UH I WILL
TELL YOU IN MY FIFTIES HE HAD ME
UP OVER HIS HEAD TWIRLING ME,
UH, ONCE AT AN EVENT WHERE I HAD
TO SCREAM AT HIM TO PLEASE PUT
ME DOWN. IT WAS UNSIGHTLY FOR A
COUNCIL MEMBER TO BE UP IN THE
AIR. UM WE MET AS SOON AS I
MOVED TO STOCKTON AND, UH, I WAS
, UH, ACCEPTED INTO HIS CIRCLE
OF FRIENDS, WHICH WAS WIDE AND
VARIED. AND THERE WERE SO MANY
NAMES FOR DANNY. UM LET ME SAY
HE GOT IN A TERRIBLE CAR WRECK
IN HIS TWENTIES, UH, IN WHICH HE
WAS A VERY GOOD LOOKING MAN. BIG
BUFF, UH, BUT COULD DRESS UP
LIKE A LADY IN TWO SECONDS. UM
UH, IN A VERY CRUSHED HIS FACE.
HE LOST AN EYE AND HE CRUSHED
HIS FACE. UM AND HIS SISTER AT
THE TIME, SAID HE'S NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE IT. HE'S SUCH A
PEACOCK. HOW COULD HE GO ON? BUT
HE TRULY FELT LIKE HE WAS
VISITED BY GOD. HE WAS A VERY
RELIGIOUS PERSON. HE FELT LIKE
GOD CAME TO HIM. BLESSED HIM,
PUT A VEIL OVER HIM AND TOLD HIM
NOW YOU GO FORWARD IN LOVE, SO
HE FELT LIKE HE HAD A SECOND
CHANCE AT LIFE AND LOVE. HE DID,
UM, THERE WAS NOBODY NÓ ESTATE
SALE THAT WAS SAFE FROM HIM. NÓ
PARTY THAT WAS SAFE. HE WAS A
GOOD HOST. AS HE WAS A GUEST. HE
ALWAYS CAME. HE ALWAYS BROUGHT
PROPS. HE ALWAYS, UH, CAME WITH
LOVE. HE HAD A VERY WIDE CIRCLE
OF FRIENDS, UM, FROM ANYBODY WHO
WORKED FOR WITH AT POOR FEES TO
THE TO THE, UH, JEWELRY. UH, HE
WOULD TELL ME STORIES OF
UPSELLING PEOPLE A LOT OF
JEWELRY I'M LIKE, BUT, GIRL,
THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT. HE GOES G
GIRL. THEY FEEL FABULOUS. AND
LOOK WHAT THEY'RE GONNA GIVE TO
THEIR GIRLFRIEND. THEY'RE GONNA
BE THE JUST MAKING PEOPLE FEEL
GOOD WAS HIS CALLING IN LIFE AND
WHAT HE TOOK MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE. UM HE DREW HIS LAST BREATH
AND HE, UH HE DEVELOPED, UH UH,
COLON CANCER 12 YEARS AGO AND
LIVED WITH COLON CANCER AND
THRIVED WITH COLON CANCER. UH,
STILL HAVING PARTIES WOULD TAKE
HIM BACK AND FORTH TO CHEMO. UH
AT ONE POINT, HE GOT DOWN TO 145
FROM A MAN WHO BOARDED AROUND
THREE 100, BUT STILL HE FOUGHT
BACK, AND STILL, HE WOULD.
SOMETIMES WHEN HE WOULD HAVE BAD
PAIN, HE WOULD SAY, GIRL. I JUST
OPEN UP THE DRAWER, PUT MY
FINGER IN IT AND CLOSE IT REAL
HARD, BECAUSE THAT TAKES THE
PAIN TO MY FINGER AND AWAY FROM
EVERYTHING ELSE. UM, EVERY
HOSPITAL HE VISITED, HE WAS
FAVORITE ON THE WARD BECAUSE HE
WOULD BRING HIS FABRIC HE HAD TO
HAVE, UH, PRINTS OVER THE WALLS.
UH I CAN'T TELL YOU THE AMOUNT
OF EVENTS WE WENT TO OR HE WOULD
WALK UP TO A CROWD, AND I WOULD
THINK OH, MY GOD, WE'RE ALL
GONNA DIE. IF YOU'RE GÂY, UH,
YOU GO INTO SOME CROWDS, AND YOU
THINK THIS IS NOT A FRIENDLY
PLACE FOR US? UH OH, WE'RE IN
TROUBLE, AND DANNY WOULD GO UP
AND BEFORE I KNEW IT, THESE BIG
GUYS WOULD BE DRESSED WITH HATS
ON AND JEWELRY AND PURSES AND
CAMPING IT UP, AND EVERY TIME WE
WOULD LEAVE, PEOPLE WOULD SAY,
WHEN IS DANNY COMING BACK? UH,
ONE OF OUR DEAR FRIENDS MOVED TO
PUERTO VALLARTA ABOUT A DECADE
AGO. DANNY HAS MADE HIS HOME
BETWEEN PUERTO VALLARTA AND HERE
, UH, AND HAD A GOOD TIME.
THEY'VE HAD FUNERALS FOR HIM IN
PUERTO VALLARTA. WE WILL, UH,
CELEBRATE HIS LIFE. ON SATURDAY.
HE ASKED THAT NÓ. HE DON'T WANT
ANYBODY CRYING. HE WOULD, BUT
ANYBODY CARRYING ON BUT HE
WANTED A FABULOUS PARTY AND HE
WAS WORRIED ABOUT WHO WAS GOING
TO DECORATE, AND I CAN ASSURE
HIM THAT THE BOYS AND THE GIRLS
ARE SPENDING ALL THESE THREE
DAYS TO DECORATE FOR HIS PARTY.
HE DEVELOPED LUNG CANCER SIX
YEARS AGO AND LIVED WITH LUNG
CANCER. AFTER RECOVERING FROM
THE COLON CANCER. IT WAS ALREADY
A STAGE FOUR WHEN HE HAD IT, UH
AND HE LIVED EVERY SINGLE DAY
THAT HE COULD UNTIL THE VERY END
. UH, IT'S STILL HARD TO BELIEVE
HE'S GONE. IF PEOPLE KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT ME, THEY KNOW I
LOVE TO COOK. HE WAS MY BIGGEST
BEST EATER. UH, THE TIME SITTING
IN MY KITCHEN AS I'M FIXING HIM
FOOD, HE'S REGALING ME WITH
STORIES. ALMOST TRUE, BUT HE
ALWAYS TOLD ME MY FOOD WAS GREAT
TOO. I WILL MISS HIM THE REST OF
MY LIFE. UH, HE HELPED ME BE A
BETTER PARENT BECAUSE HE WOULD
SAY, GIRL JUST LOVE JUST LOVE
JUST LOVE. ONE OF MY FAVORITE
THINGS, HE SAID. WHEN PEOPLE
REMEMBER I BECAME A PARENT CAN
ACCIDENTALLY MY SISTER IN LAW
DIED. AND IN A MONTH I HAD A
CHILD AND DANNY SAID. WELL, GIRL
, AT LEAST SHE'S PRETTY AND
SMART. SHE COULD BE DUMB AND
UGLY. RIGHT UH, SO THAT WAS
DANNY ALWAYS TURNING EVERYTHING
INTO HOW ARE WE GONNA CELEBRATE
THIS? WHAT IS THAT BRIGHT SIDE
OF IT? UH, I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
THIS SENATE IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN. THE
STANDARD EXTENDS ITS CONDOLENCES
TO THE FAMILY AND FRIENDS OF DÂN
. JIMENEZ IF YOU'D PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL. NEXT STEP. WE'D
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR OCHOA
BOGUE. AS HARD TO FOLLOW I EGM
OH, SO TODAY. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. IT IS
WITH GREAT. UH, SORRY. IT IS
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF CLAIRE
CAMPBELL TEETERS WHO PASSED AWAY
IN JANUARY. 29TH 2024 AT AGE 76
AFTER BRAVELY BATTLING
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE. THE ELDEST
OF SEVEN CHILDREN. CLAIRE WAS
BORN IN A MILITARY FAMILY IN
MICHIGAN ON JULY 31ST 1947. IN
THE MID 19 SIXTIES, CLAIRE
ATTENDED VICTOR VALLEY COLLEGE
AND THEN TOOK A JOB AT SAINT
MARY'S HOSPITAL IN APPLE VALLEY.
IN THE 19 SEVENTIES, SHE MOVED
TO KAM MESA AND THEN SETTLED IN
YUCAIPA, WHERE SHE WORKED AS
MANAGER OF THE RADIOLOGY
DEPARTMENT AT YUCAIPA MEDICAL
CLINIC. IT WAS THERE SHE MET
BARBARA RIORDAN, A MEMBER OF THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR. CLAIRE WAS HER FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE FOR 13 YEARS.
WHILE WORKING FOR SUPERVISOR
REARDON. CLAIRE JOINED THE Y, A
MUNICIPAL ADVISORY COUNCIL AS
ONE OF NINE RESIDENTS WHO
ADVISED THE COUNTY ON LOCAL
ISSUES, INCLUDING THE
INCORPORATION OF THE NEW CITY OF
YUCAIPA. FOLLOWING SUPERVISOR
RIORDAN'S TENURE, CLAIRE BECAME
EDITOR OF THE U Kò P KAM MESA
NEWS MIRROR IN 1997, COVERING
MAJOR LOCAL EVENTS UNTIL HER
RETIREMENT IN 2017. A DEVOTED
HISTORIAN, CLAIRE SERVED AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE YUCAIPA VALLEY
HISTORICAL SOCIETY AND SPENT
TIME VOLUNTEERING AT THE MUSEUM.
SHE WAS ALSO A MEMBER OF THE GEM
AND MINERAL SOCIETY IN THE
YUCCA, A WOMEN'S CLUB. 1990 SHE
JOINED THE YUCAIPA ROTARY WAS
NAMED ROTARIAN OF THE YEAR IN
1994 AND RECEIVED A ROTARY
LIFETIME MEMBERSHIP IN 2022.
CLAIRE TEETERS WAS CONSIDERED BY
MANY AS THE MATRIARCH OF OUR
CITY. SHE WAS NON KNOWN TO CALL
PEOPLE OUT WHEN THEY WOULD ACT
OR SPEAK LESS THAN HONORABLY OR
TRUTHFULLY. HER PRAISE HAD WE.
CLAIRE IS SURVIVED BY HER SONS,
MICHAEL GRAY, DANIEL GRAY AND
JIM TEETERS DAUGHTER SHELLY
TEETERS AND GRANDSON CORBE GREY.
I WISH CLAIRE'S FAMILY AND MANY
FRIENDS, PEACE AND COMFORT
DURING THIS TIME OF DEEP SORROW.
I WOULD BE HONORED. THIS IS A
PARTY BUT A JOURNEY IN HER
MEMORY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
OCHOA. B¢O, UH, SENATOR SENDS
THEIR OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE
FRIENDS AND FAMILY OF CLAIRE ERS
. PLEASE BRING HER NAME FORWARD
SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE SENATE
JOURNAL. IF THERE WAS NÓ OTHER
BUSINESS BEFORE THE SENATE,
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MR
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS HOPE YOU HAVE
A WONDERFUL WEEKEND. UH,
INCREDIBLY MOVING. ADJOURNING
MEMORIES. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY, FEBRUARY 26TH AT 2 P.M.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE PM AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED. WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT 2 P.M.